[Music]
hello and welcome to the reason
Roundtable I'm Peter shooterman filling
in for Matt Welch who is offline mixing
metaphors like I mix cocktails happy
Tuesday
I am joined by my regular co-panelists
Catherine mangy Ward and nicholaspi as
well as special guest Zach Weissmuller
everyone say hello hi
hey howdy so yesterday was President's
Day and that means that we are going to
spend much of this week's podcast
talking about presidents we will start
with the current occupant of the White
House Joe Biden in a segment I will call
the reign in Ukraine falls mainly on the
plane
okay so over the weekend President Biden
made a surprise visit to Ukraine
spending time in the capital city of
Kiev where he promised an additional
half billion dollars in Aid on top of
the tens of billions of dollars the U.S
has already committed Biden also
announced that America was set to impose
additional sanctions on Russia with a
focus on the energy sector the the visit
came on the eve of the one-year
anniversary of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine Biden's visit also preceded a
major speech planned for today from
Poland in which he was expected to frame
the war as a battle for democracy and
reiterate his and thus America's
unwavering commitment to backing Ukraine
in the war
also today Russian leader of Vladimir
Putin is expected to deliver a speech
making his case for the war that it is a
program of denotification that it is
essential to warding off a threat from
NATO and that it is aimed at reclaiming
historical Russian territory whatever it
takes in short both leaders are expected
to say that they will continue the war
until the other one backs down the
result is going to be what the New York
Times called a split screen moment with
cold war parallels a showdown of sorts
between two aging cold Warriors one 70
years old and another who just turned 80
who've been circling each other for
years and are now engaged in everything
short of direct battle so to start today
I just want to go around the panel
engage a reaction to Biden's visit and
to America's continuing commitment to
backing Ukraine in the war Nick let's
start with you I think Biden's visit is
fine he was the last of the major kind
of European uh leaders to actually go to
Ukraine I think our Aid is too much and
it needs more controls on it this is
it's not a good thing to be getting into
a war you know a little bit at a time
like Biden is slipping into a bath
that's a little bit too warm for his
wrinkled skin the other thing you know I
just want to say real quick in the uh
the the summary that you read it's
really [__] dangerous to keep
personalizing these kinds of events this
isn't Putin versus Biden it's the United
States and a bunch of Western Nations
versus Russia and just like in the Cold
War there was always an attempt to try
and Link everything to the personalities
of a couple of leaders one of them may
not even be popularly elected uh that's
really dangerous and we need to be
focusing on the on the broader forces
that are leading to this kind of
standoff I think that's fair although I
do also think that the Biden and Putin
are that inevitably the personifications
of their nation's policy objectives here
we are you know America is doing what
Biden wants in Ukraine and and Russia is
doing what Putin wants to some degree
it's obviously not just them but they
are pivotal figures here Catherine uh
what was your reaction to Biden's
Ukraine visit
you know I read a bunch of the kind of
mainstream coverage of it and one thing
that I was struck by was everyone wants
it to be cold war parallels but some of
the framing actually struck me much more
as Iraq war parallels uh on Putin's side
of things so
um The New York Times wrote Vladimir
Putin who a year ago this week believed
the Ukrainian Capital would become a
russian-controlled territory in a matter
of days uh moving Mr Putin closer to his
ambition of restoring the Empire of
Peter the Great right and I do think
there is
you know there is some something to be
glean there of you know the idea that
Putin thought he was going to sweep in
take over get the job done get out
cleanly uh maybe also a little World War
One energy there a little like this war
will be brief and provide opportunities
for Valor and then you know everyone had
trench foot and it was really sad so I
think that there is there is
the temptation to go Cold War parallel
is there but there are many other
parallels of course parallels to all
wars are bad news in the end because
they're still Wars and the other thing I
was struck by was many many quotes that
had some variation of you know if this
war lasts like a really really long time
Russia has the upper hand and that's
just manifestly true right like there
will there is an expiration on the
tolerance of the U.S Congress among
other things for backing financially
backing this war and Putin will do this
literally until the day he dies
and I think that that's
was obvious from the beginning and it's
weird to me that we're still doing the
you know kind of
um to be sure in mainstream coverage of
this war
I saw a bunch of those quotes too
although several of them that I saw uh
were caveated with uh Russia will have
the upper hand if this lasts for a long
time that is if the United States and
NATO backed down and it's so it was
basically framed this as a war between
Russia and the NATO U.S Coalition uh
where it was the NATO U.S resolve that
mattered actually in some ways more than
Ukraine itself Zach what was your
reaction to the to the visit well I
agree with Catherine that this has in a
way demystified both Putin and kind of
the the might of the Russian military
there was a lot of early speculation
that they were just going to roll all
the way into Kiev and you know that
obviously didn't happen and it's all
part of a a demystification that's
happened across the world really I mean
Trump I think taking power in the U.S
had that effect on many Americans view
of our federal government certainly the
executive branch and now with kind of
the the the decline of Biden there you
know the the might of the U.S is also in
question and that's why I I that's one
reason I would really reject the uh Cold
War comparison uh you know most of the
Cold War played out before I was born
but just from my understanding of
History you know there was an appetite
for military spending and a kind of
post-world War II belief in American
might and the federal government being
somewhat competent the space race was
really exciting for people communism was
a clear and obvious threat and I think
now none of that's there uh we're on the
heels of two decades of Middle East Wars
with very little show for it uh trust
and confidence in the federal
governments extremely low and for a very
good reason uh and Russia is a threat to
Eastern Europe uh but it's so far
removed from the power of the Soviet
Union and not driven by the pernicious
ideology of Communism that Americans
rightly saw as a threat to their way of
life the main parallel I see with the
Cold War at this point is the occasional
and terrifying saber rattling about the
use of nuclear weapons yeah so I I mean
I I agree with that this isn't Cold War
II Cold War harder right it's not a
direct sequel this is it's this and it's
more like the legend of Curly's gold
Cold War too shitty Slickers 2.0 rather
than uh die hard 2. yeah so Nick uh I
want to ask you about die hard too no I
don't actually I want to ask you you do
I like it it's an Easter move we need
more Easter movies one of the only
movies set at the Dulles Airport
um now normally we give the Biden tweets
to Catherine but today I want to read a
White House tweet uh so it's technically
from the White House official accounts
and I'll read that to you and then ask
you about it all uh on edge waiting to
hear it yeah so the Tweet is today
President Biden is in Kiev to refer
reaffirm America's unwavering commitment
to Ukraine's democracy sovereignty and
territorial Integrity the United States
of America will stand with Ukrainian
people for as long as it takes and I
want to focus in on two little passages
there one is just one word unwavering
and the second is the final set of words
as long as it takes so does this sound
more than a little like an unofficial
declaration of war or at least proxy war
on the part of the United States against
Russia I mean an unlimited commitments
to pursuing to backing a war sounds like
you're a participant in the war it
sounds like we're at War what do you
make of this I think that what uh that
is about or it's two tracks one is that
it is a message to Putin
um you know that along with the rest of
Europe uh the United States is not going
to sit idly by when territorial you know
Integrity is is
broken and the other thing that he's
doing uh you know because and I'm sure
we'll get to this but as 2024 looms what
he is doing is he is setting out an
agenda that the Republicans will respond
to uh in Congress and I think you know
almost always domestic foreign policy in
the United States is a function of
domestic policy and what he's trying to
do is to define the Republican party as
a pro-putin party with this kind of
rhetoric uh because when people say and
Republicans you know they they haven't
figured out how to do this quite yet um
you know because they love the wars in
Afghanistan and in Iraq and they love
the American Military and now they're
going to be saying no we need less of
that
um are they going to talk about cutting
defense spending uh Biden has you know
last year as well as this year he's
looking at record-setting uh budget uh
budget uh uh calls for the defense
department and things like that I think
as much that tweet is as much about
domestic policy and setting a um uh you
know creating a difference between him
and the likely Republican uh candidates
for president
Zach is there a way to back down from
this without caving into Russia's
territorial aggression I mean Putin is
in the wrong here Russia's war is a war
of aggression uh there's no
justification for it so how should the
U.S respond to such a flagrant violation
of international Norms not to mention
any human rights abuse is just like also
killing an awful lot of people uh in a
war for territory look what should the
United States first of all maybe one way
of thinking about this question is what
should the United United States have
done from the beginning but now that
we're in the position we're in what
should we do now
yes so Nick and I actually talked with
Emma Ashford about this question she is
in the realist camp and I have an
increasing level of sympathy towards
that idea that we need to assess the
fact that you know for or recognize the
fact that the U.S is by far the largest
monetary and weapons contributor to
Ukraine at this end with that comes a
responsibility to think about the end
game from the beginning and you know
unfortunately there's you know no
fairy tale ending here where Russia I
think it's pushed back uh beyond
anything like that Russia gains no
territory whatsoever you know there's
going to be some sort of compromise I
cannot say what that is going to be but
so far the US has shown zero interest in
kind of flexing that that power they
have as a provider and Backer of Ukraine
to bring the parties to the table to to
try to to broker that and and that's
what's concerning to me especially when
I I continue to hear that rhetoric of
you know an endless commitment uh that
you know there's no there's no
discussion of that and uh that's what I
find really disturbing about our current
predicament if I may uh to the question
that you uh asked towards the end there
it it will be extremely easy uh assuming
that some kind of diplomacy is happening
if the United States and if Joe Biden
can say you know what I brokered an end
to the war in Ukraine and parts of
Ukraine are now effectively or openly
under Russian control I'm a peacemaker
people in America would love that I
think you know just from a political
point of view because nobody everybody
knows that Ukraine is not in the you
know uh you know essential National
Security 30 interests of the United
States a a fairly stable Europe is but
if if Biden presides over an end to this
Ward nobody cares what he said uh right
up until the minute that the peace
papers are signed and it is kind of like
you know a lesson learned somewhat like
that's part of this right is that you
don't want to send the message that a
power like Russia can invade a sovereign
country like Ukraine and pay no cost
they have paid a cost they paid a very
high cost and part of the agreement you
know can be continuing to pay that cost
but uh I think you're you're right that
uh that there is a way to
bring you know be The Peacemaker uh run
run on 20 run in 2024 as The Peacemaker
president and I think that would be at
this point in our kind of fiscal
domestic domestic situation that would
be a powerful message
so since Zach brought up the fiscal
aspect here I want to ask you Catherine
what you think about the the finances
here another half billion dollars is in
the scheme of a six trillion dollar
federal budget honestly not all that
much money but it is on top of about a
hundred and thirteen billion or so in
various forms of Aid military and
non-military that Congress has already
approved and as the White House tweet
reminded us this is an unwavering
commitment for as long as it takes that
does not sound like this is 113 billion
and no more it sounds like there's a lot
more coming what do you think of this
and how should we be thinking about the
the the the fiscal aspect of uh of
America's backing Ukraine in the war
yeah I mean I think in the 21st century
all of America's Wars or
proxy wars semi-wars kind of Wars I
don't even know what this is
um they're all forever Wars like that's
just one way to think about it is you
know in the same way that there's this
line that I keep coming back to you know
don't pass a law unless you're willing
to kill someone to enforce it like don't
get involved in their National conflict
unless you're willing to be in that
conflict forever
I think that is a rule of thumb that we
pretend isn't real like there was when
you know when we passed the first and
the second and the third and the fourth
package of Aid to Ukraine each time
there was this fiction this pretense
that maybe after this I don't know
Ukraine was going to be independent and
really just strike out on its own to
finish up this war like I don't know
what the theory was but that was kind of
the
unspoken implication even though
everyone who knew anything about
anything
recognized that that was not the case so
yeah 113 billion dollars is a lot of
money and there's no clear path in fact
Biden is signaling he's not even looking
for a path to shrink that number or to
bring it down to zero and I think I
think it matters do you know there's
this sort of phenomenon right where when
you ask Americans hey how can we cut the
federal budget there are a few things
that they want to cut and one of them is
foreign aid and that's a stupid answer
because foreign aid is a very small part
of the federal budget and the problem is
entitlements but it shows something
about where American sentiments are with
respect to this and it's not 113 million
dollars every year for forever that's
not where American people
um by and large end up if you ask them
the question abstractly now I I do think
you know as long as it takes uh as Zach
and Nick have both noted could easily be
until the U.S gets sick of this pressure
is Ukraine to come to a negotiated
settlement and then everyone kind of
says like oh we figured it out and it's
over now
which um you know I think that's to some
extent outside of the control of the US
I will say I don't know how much we want
to get into it but I talked with some
folks here in DC this weekend who are
you live in Washington DC I live in
Washington DC and here in DC this
weekend I talked to some folks who are
not terribly political but happen to be
down on the mall for President's Day and
they bumped into a big rally down there
and uh they were like hey were these
your guys was this you
I whatever that was that's not the way
out either just to be clear
um you know standing in front of a bunch
of Russian Flags shouting about Julian
Assange is not going to solve this
problem either
um so for what it's worth
we don't have a lot of good options and
I get that all right speaking of uh
races contests that don't have a lot of
good options let's talk about the GOP
Presidential race on the other side of
the aisle the 2024 Republican
presidential primary is heating up with
a new entrant into the field and some
revealing sniping between the players
and expected players so we're gonna name
this segment after the widely recognized
modern classic Adam Sandler movie Little
Nicky yes folks that's right Nikki Haley
the former governor of South Carolina
and U.S ambassador to the UN is
officially running for president Haley
has been swimming in GOP waters for well
over a decade but she's running on a
theme of Welcome to the Next Generation
over the weekend she tweeted out we keep
hearing the same thing across the
country Americans are tired of the
status quo they want a leader with fresh
ideas and a track record of success Nick
you're tired of this status quo aren't
you yeah so what everything does uh what
does Haley bring to the GOP race is she
really the next generation of Republican
no and I would have named this section
darling darling Nikki uh rather than
Little Nicky Peter
uh you wouldn't even had to change the
spelling of her name I'll ask for
submissions next time I think that would
be a good thing and be bury him in there
we're gonna do it we're gonna do a
segment naming contest
what Nikki Haley brings is a completely
forgotten record as a two-term governor
of South Carolina where according to the
Cato Institute she increased outlays by
her oversaw an increase in allies of 38
percent and in 2016 the last time they
did their gubernatorial scorecard when
she was in office was a d from a
Libertarian perspective uh there's not a
lot in Nikki Haley she left office
worked for Donald Trump at the UN for a
while and had a semi acrimonious break
with him about that but not so much I
mean she's uh you know give her credit
for getting out there first but she as
far as I can tell other than the shot uh
that uh people over 75
in politics should have to go through
some kind of reading comprehension or
mental competency test she's added very
little to the um to the discourse and I
predict she'll early in early out
Zach normally I play the role of Florida
man on this podcast but you actually
live in Florida now like today by choice
even and there's a Santa stand you mean
yeah yeah that's that's exactly what I
mean so right you're living under the
governorship of Ron DeSantis who has not
officially announced a run for president
but is widely expected to be the main
rival to former president Trump uh with
this early announcement though it does
seem like maybe Hayley wants to play
that role too so how do you see the
contrast between Haley and DeSantis what
does that tell us about the state of the
GOP field and the race that we can
expect to see over the next couple years
yeah so I uh the comment that I saw her
make about DeSantis was so desantis's
you know famously passed this law here
called the parental rights and Education
Act critics call it the don't say gay
law and says you know grades K through
three you can't talk about gender
identity or sexuality and uh Nikki Haley
was like I think that's that's really
wrong it should be K through seven and
so it's like if her strategy is gonna be
I'm going to you know Ron DeSantis isn't
Ron desantisy enough I really don't
think that's going to work for her uh
because you know you can agree or
disagree with his policies but it's
pretty clear to anyone paying attention
that he's pushing this stuff forward
with uh more force uh than just about
any other politician with a national
profile and honestly that's also some of
Trump's uh challenge because he's out
there saying you know look Florida
actually did lock down for a couple of
months and like nobody is gonna buy a
any of that we we all saw what happened
and you know if if someone is going to
cut a real contrast with Trump and
DeSantis I think you'd want someone who
actually wants to offer a path for
transcending the culture wars and also
wants to break with the really
protectionist and heavy-handed National
conservatism that Trump brought into the
party and that I think DeSantis is kind
of distilling
um that allows a lot of space for the
government to shape social policy
um and so I you know that is when I will
get a little more excited uh for an
entrance into the GOP race but I'm not
holding my breath this is about an
unwavering commitment to the war on woke
right the GOP candidates are going to
fight for as long as it takes
never give up against uh uh Public
School teachers okay Catherine you may
not have noticed but here's something
about Nikki Haley she's a woman
thank you specifically
what is a woman Peter to find that
before yeah wait wait that was actually
my quest my question for Catherine so
specifically she's a woman running for
the presidential nomination of the
Republic of the Republican party which
has led to headlines like this one from
the New York Times Haley walks
treacherous road for GOP women Nikki
Haley's presidential campaign is a major
test for parties using sexism and female
leaders just don't call it identity
politics so Catherine if you're not
going to call it identity politics what
are you gonna call it
um and more seriously there is in fact a
completely undisguised gender Dynamic
here part of Haley's own pitch is that
she and this is a quote is a tough as
Nails woman
what do you think about that
I read this New York Times article with
it just was like pure rage right into my
veins because the gotcha of this piece
the like clever twist that the New York
Times came up with was the GOP says
identity politics are not good for
America but Mickey Haley is still
acknowledging on the campaign Trail
repeatedly that she is a lady
oh got her wow they really they nailed
her to the wall with that one like I
it's and it's thousands of words this is
like a long thinky piece and it's just
over and over like they say they don't
like identity politics but then she
mentioned that she wears heels ha it's
like okay
so obviously there's gonna be a lot of
that
for as long as she was in the race I
tend to agree
um that we may
as long as she is in the race may not be
that long
um and that's fine with me because I
just don't see anything particularly
appealing about her political ideology
as I can discern it or how she would
govern in so far as I can tell
um
I think that there is going to be a
pretty delicious moment though if she
does make it through
fairly far in the campaign
um where people on the left will
potentially be forced to confront
you know here's a a path breaker a woman
like we're supposed to celebrate this
and yet she's a Republican and therefore
a moral monster so what can we do how
can we celebrate female success well
also just hating Republicans with all of
our beings
I guess it's helpful that thanks to
Kamala Harris she won't be the first uh
you know woman of Asian descent she
won't be the first I mean you know she's
Harris has like beat her to some of
those firsts uh unless she actually sent
her the nomination and the presidency so
maybe they can just avoid that
conversation altogether but
um but yeah the gender politics of Nikki
Haley are going to be excruciating I do
hope that people are able to kind of get
it out of their systems quickly
um along with the racial politics which
have already been embarrassing for
everyone involved
um including this like she made up her
name she anglicized her name fight which
she has had over and over in her career
and is going to have to have again as
she reintroduces herself to more and
more like larger swaths of the American
public but yeah she's just she's she has
all the same problems of DeSantis as far
as I can tell as a substantive leader
but less of the appeal and so I just
don't know why anyone would be
getting on the Haley bandwagon at this
point embarrassing for everyone involved
is a great segue to my next question
which is for Nick
and it's about Donald Trump Donald Trump
has more or less officially been running
since late last year although he hasn't
always acted like it but at this point
he's starting to step up his game in
particular by attacking his Rivals after
promising not to call Ron DeSantis
meatball Rod I really love that too I
swear is like a lost Garbage Pail Kids
character if you remember those from the
1980s
definitely was coming out of his face
he's so excited if that were like in my
Garbage Pail Kids a collectible card
pack
um so if you're promising not to to use
that nickname Trump recently posted on
his social network truth social Rhonda
sanctimonious wants to cut your Social
Security and Medicare closed up Florida
and its beaches loves rhinos Paul Ryan
Jeb Bush and Karl Rove
disasters all there's some exclamation
points some capital letters here is
backed by globalists club for no growth
Lincoln pervert project and uninspired
Coke and it only gets worse from there
I'm assuming he's talking about his own
tweets uh he is a rhino in Disguise
that's Trump again so that's a bunch of
words and exclamation points uh which
are kind of funny in a way but in some
ways it adds up to a more or less
coherent critique uh what Trump is
saying more or less is that Ron DeSantis
is a conventional Republican of the sort
who routinely won State and National
races in the Republican party right up
until 2015 when Trump entered the
picture so what does it say about the
state of the Republican party and really
the state of American politics when
someone of Trump's stature a former
president a likely 2024 Presidential
nominee again
when he's complaining that the other
candidate in the Republican race is is
too Republican I guess
like what do you make of that I I don't
really understand I mean one of the
things that it clarifies is that Trump
you know who in two consecutive
presidential races got around 46 a
little bit more than 46 percent of the
popular vote
has nowhere to go
um I think you know his role going
forward in the Republican party and in
National politics is to kneecap whoever
the Republican candidate is uh could be
him or it could be somebody else but
it's like part of his following is going
to be against the Republican candidate
no matter who it is
um and I think in his incoherence he was
able to uh you know kind of capture a
public mood particularly against
somebody like Hillary Clinton
um with a bunch of complaints that were
scattered and don't make sense as a
critique of anything the really
troubling aspect to me is the fact that
people like Ron DeSantis meatball Ron
Ron sanctimonious all of that kind of
stuff like they're not talking about
anything that has to do with overall
federal spending and the effect that
that has on the economy or on the
ability of America to regenerate itself
to reach spawn well to the extent they
are talking about it it's to just
absolutely take off the table uh any
kind of cuts to see old age senior
entitlements because
fairly straightforward political reasons
which is that a lot of uh older people
vote Republican well and also defense
spending right I mean like you don't
hear it's it's virtually impossible for
a republican the only person who really
got far doing this was Ron Paul to some
degree Rand Paul but you know when you
if you if you are not going to be
massively trimming or talking about a
different way of funding Social Security
Medicare and defense spending you cannot
cut any spending whatsoever I don't know
if you saw that that's where we're at I
don't know if you saw that clip
circulating I think in the Trump Circles
of DeSantis back because DeSantis was uh
you know a tea party guy back in the day
and he was on tape talking about uh you
know uh kind of privatizing or means
testing Social Security and then that
was being used by the Trump team to go
after him so that yeah the to that to
Nick's Point like yes this is now Trump
is trying to make like the absolute
sanctity of Social Security and
entitlement State you know new GOP
Orthodoxy which it has been though I
mean that's the most important thing at
least since Reagan in his second term
when he said saving Social Security and
Medicare for another generation was his
greatest accomplishment in office and
this is a guy who effectively won the
Cold War
um you know the Republicans have never
been serious about actually cutting any
of this stuff and this is where somebody
like Nikki Haley who has who is not
going to go anywhere would have been
fascinating if she actually articulated
a different framework for what the
federal government is for how to how
much should it spend and what should it
be uh you know but we're obviously not
going to get that from the Republicans
this time I do think there has been a
real shift here I will put in a little
hype for um our cover story of the next
issue which should be hitting your
inboxes and mailboxes uh right about now
um Eric Bame wrote about DeSantis and um
he starts with DeSantis tea party past
um and I think Nick is quite right that
there was never a moment where
Republicans were seriously
focused on cutting or majorly reforming
entitlements but there was a moment and
that was the moment that desantis's
career was born in which they sounded
like they meant it there were of course
still the Tea Party signs that said
government hands off my medicare and all
that but but you know there there are
plenty of gotchas in desantis's past if
what you are looking for is evidence
that he might have at some point thought
our current entitlement system is
unsustainable and said that out loud
um so in that sense you know I want to
believe that guy is in there somewhere
but I actually like Ron de sanctimonious
because that is who he's running as now
yeah it's really remarkable I mean the
Tea Party had many many problems both in
terms of the way it conducted itself
it's just sort of in its attitudes in
its level of seriousness
um in what it evolved into I think uh
but it is pretty remarkable that
post-t-party Republicans have rejected
basically everything that the Tea Party
stood for even if only rhetorically in
favor of I'm not even actually sure what
right there's a there's a faction of
Republicans at this point who are
against just about everything including
it seems the Republican Party itself uh
okay so let's go to an advertisement
here
self-reliance planning ahead using our
heads those are just a few of the things
we believe in here at the reason
Roundtable and that's why we'd like to
tell you about the air Med Care Network
membership and how it can take a
financial worry off your plate airmed
Care Network is America's largest
emergency air ambulance membership
Network airmed Care Network providers
operate state-of-the-art helicopters and
their specially trained medical
personnel provide the highest level of
pre-hospital Medical Care in emergency
situations even with insurance these
flights can be very expensive but when
you're an airmed Care Network member you
won't see a bill for your flight only
when flown by one of their providers
this is a financial safety net you
should have membership is amazingly
affordable only 99 per year and just 79
dollars for seniors and your entire
household is covered right now our
listeners get up to an 80 Mastercard or
Amazon e-gift card when they join amcn
and use offer code reason visit
airmedcarenetwork.com forward slash
reason today
alright so next we have a question from
listener Afton Wolfe who says he's a big
fan happy Monday except it's happy
Tuesday here so the question is I'm sure
you've discussed it before but where do
you guys fall on intellectual property
rights a number of Libertarians seem to
think that intellectual property is not
actual property that ideas are for
everyone they say these intangibles are
not eligible for property rights and
that copyright and patent systems uh
particularly enable monopolies and
abuses of said system and then with AI
advancement this is I think the the most
interesting part of the question the
question gets murkier as to who owns it
the monkey taking the picture
or the photographer who left the camera
for it right so if chat GPT or dolly or
whatever one of these AI systems is
using is taking material that is
copyrighted by other people and then
modifying it what then the listener
writes I don't necessarily believe that
there has to be a government registry to
protect these rights but I also see
intellectual property as originating and
therefore belonging to the Creator this
person is a creative themselves and they
like to think of creativity more as
Discovery and just like if someone found
a vein of gold that person would have
senior and Superior rights to exploit it
what say you panelists also I will say
this person is a musician you can check
out their music online so Nick what do
we think about intellectual property
rights in the age of AI
I think uh until you know the current
basic framework of intellectual property
is a you know plus or minus 200 years
old it is due for a major rethink
because unlike what the letter writer
says uh intellectual property is
explicitly in the Constitution a
government grant of Monopoly for a
certain period of time we used to write
a lot about this uh towards the end of
the 20th century in the beginning of the
21st the copyright terms in particular
kept getting extended keep getting
extended every time Mickey Mouse and a
couple of other properties are about to
become public domain the abuse of that
uh led to a kind of cap copyright uh
anarchism uh which resides heavily in
libertarian circles and I'm very
sympathetic towards it
um the main thing to think about I think
over the past 20 years and as we're
going into an AI phase where all sorts
of stuff is going to be you know written
or produced without clear Providence
consumers and this is ultimately what
it's about it's not about actually
protecting uh creators rights because
people keep creating stuff whether or
not there's copyrights but consumers and
industries can flourish as long as
consumers can get a steady reliable flow
of material
um you know all of the arguments about
Napster in the late 90s kind of faded
you know there were un I think
indefensible government actions to take
down Napster and things like that but
once you get Pandora and Spotify and
people have reliable good streaming to
basically everything and you throw in
SoundCloud where people who don't have
record label deals can get their stuff
out or YouTube or whatever
the issue about copyright really uh kind
of Retreats the business models will
change but the real main thing is that
our able are people able to find the
stuff that they want to consume that's
really what's going to govern all of
this and then we'll write the laws after
the fact to kind kind of justify a
system that's working for people Zach
you are a creator of video content
yourself how do you feel about AI coming
in and taking it and transforming it
combining it with other things and
making something new out I do want to
point out that Zach technically doesn't
own any of his intellectual property uh
property it's all it's all it's all
reason that's right and reason actually
doesn't own it we put all our videos in
the Creative Commons and people take it
and remix it all the time so I mean you
know it's legitimate for peop artists
creators to want to monetize their work
of course and people are generally very
happy to pay for it in different ways
luckily the digital era has allowed for
these these new business models to to
spring up whether it's you know
crowdfunding
um or you know a a non-profit backing
you or uh you know corporations figuring
out ways to present their their content
in uh more accessible easy ways like you
know create reading their own streaming
service but I think that that's where
most of this when especially comes to
the Arts should rest with with the
creators to figure out ways to make
money and to you know create a little
Walled Garden or or whatever around
their content I don't think we need the
government so involved in protecting
copyright at this point because the the
argument that the framer is put forth is
that it's purely utilitarian does it
incentivize useful products in the realm
of Arts uh you know in the useful Arts
and Sciences and in the Arts I tend to
think that it mostly incentivizes
retreads of valuable IP when you look at
the output from Hollywood for instance
in The Sciences you know patents and so
forth maybe there's a stronger case for
it sometimes but even there you know
Elon Musk has thrown a lot of those
assumptions into question by open
sourcing a lot of his technology so you
know I'd say I am on the border between
an IP Anarchist and an extreme IP
skeptic at this point Catherine this
isn't exactly the listener's question
but we were talking before the podcast
about how the online science fiction
magazine Clark's world shut down
submissions this last week guess why
because they had been flooded with AI
written science fiction short stories
what do you think about this weird new
world of AI art generation about the
copyright implications but also about
the implications for say magazine
editors who have to read slush piles
yeah I was actually thinking about that
this weekend uh we do get a bunch of
submissions over the transom and we
sometimes run them
um it is probably only a matter of time
before we publish a partly or holy AI
composed article without knowing it at
all and I think that that's both a
little terrifying and kind of great like
I'm I generally think when you look at
an area of law that seems sort of
internally contradictory or extremely
corrupted by cronyism or just difficult
to enforce it's very rare that we
correct those problems with
legal reform it does happen but um the
idea that there's kind of going to be
one big brain that's gonna say okay
we're gonna rewrite these laws and now
they're going to work
um instead
we have technologies that emerge and
just break the whole thing right just
shatter it into pieces and I think that
that's kind of where we are with IP
right now that
um it's slow moving I think I would I
would also put it
maybe beginning as Nick notes with the
kind of Napster moment and um coming
coming to its fruition today and that
it's just going to be
unsustainable to continue to behave as
if intellectual property is real
property in the sense that our law has
attempted to embody it for the last
couple hundred years
um it doesn't mean that what happens at
the far end of that is something good
right we could easily end up with a sort
of
semi-dystopian copyright troll
scenario where everyone is just it's a
sort of War of all against all for a
while but as Virginia postrell has
written over the years many times there
are already plenty of areas of creative
and intellectual Endeavor where there
aren't strong intellectual property
protections and there's areas are
thriving including recipes and fashion
um you know perhaps not coincidentally
traditionally female Pursuits and I
think that I think that if everything
heads that way we could certainly do
worse
um than than to have our uh the you know
some of our other Industries behave more
like those Industries and Zach is right
people will figure out how to make money
like you know there's always there's
always a premium there's always a pro
there's always a plus and
um and I think you know the tool the
same tools that have broken IP or are
breaking IP as it previously existed are
also providing opportunities for
creatives to make money
people on this podcast who have
benefited from the fact that you cannot
copyright a list of ingredients
actually yeah I know it's like everybody
does and it's also you know when you
look at places like patreon and sub
stack uh you know there are more ways
now for individual creators in a
disintermediated way where you don't
have to go through a big recording label
or a corporation that is going to take a
massive cut and control the actual you
know distribution of your work you know
things things are actually very good for
small uh small creators for a kind of
bespoke artisanal creative community in
a way that they haven't been for a very
long time I recommend reading uh Grant
McCracken's the return of the artisan
and also uh almost 10 years ago no can't
be 10 years ago it's been eight years
whatever sometime in the past time is
doesn't matter it increasingly
increasingly
um but um I talked with Glenn Platt
who's a professor of interactive media
studies at Miami University about what
he calls the intimacy economy and for
decades long before Napster artists were
moving into a different relationship
with audiences who increasingly had more
options to go elsewhere and you do it by
offering premium offering early looks
things that Catherine was uh you know
mentioning just a couple minutes ago
that is going to proceed a pace because
what people want is a connection with a
source of
um you know creativity that they like
that's why podcasts you know like
blocked and reported or the fifth column
that Matt uh co-founded and co-host the
it's the community as much as anything
else that is really driving engagement
money uh and creativity so uh we're in a
in an incredibly fertile period partly
because copyright no longer can cast as
long of a shadow and the means of of
cultural production have been
democratized in radical ways incredibly
fertile except for national birth rates
being in the in the YouTube space I've
seen this firsthand I mean YouTube has
played a big role in expanding kind of
the definition of fair use where you
take a pre-existing media clip and then
just by offering some commentary on it
you are freely able to use it that is a
inherently murky concept and uh YouTube
You Know YouTube creators I think have
helped to expand that and and it's
beneficial to the smaller creators to
have more material to to work with and
so if if the goal here is you know more
abundance more creativity just I would
say the Practical effects are that a
looser IP regime seems to uh incentivize
that and a tighter IP regime seems to
disproportionately benefit the kind of
you know wealthier firms that have
really valuable IP or right so
Catherine's mention of systems that are
unsustainable is a good setup for our
final newsy segment in which we are
going to look very briefly at the
ongoing debt entitlement and economic
situation for a segment I'll call the
prices aren't right Bob
here are three pieces of news that
happened in the last week or two first
the Congressional budget office released
new projections showing that by 2033
federal government will spend as much on
Social Security as it does on Military
and all other discretionary spending
over the next decade CBO says America
will add about 19 trillion dollars in
new debt second following an inflation
report showing that consumer Prices rose
6.4 percent from a year prior which is
down from a peak in July but still
Rising quite quickly Federal Reserve
chair J Powell warned that the path to
reducing inflation in the US is probably
going to be bumpy
and finally Senator Rick Scott
Republican of Florida dropped his push
to Sunset Social Security and Medicare
following a tax and criticism from both
President Biden and Republican
leadership in congress Nick put all of
that together for me what have we
learned uh we've learned that the
government is not going to be the break
on government spending it's going to
have to come from pressure from outside
uh either economic reality uh red and
tooth and Claw or by motivated special
interest groups I.E voters who change
the direction of all of this
Zach you have done some reporting on
inflation wasn't it just a couple of
years ago that some folks mostly on the
center left were actually saying that
more inflation would be good are those
are those people happy now
yeah well you know I I spoke with I did
a video where I spoke with John Cochran
who's a debt Hawk and then uh Jason
Furman who well maybe more of a debt
inflation Dove let's say uh also served
in the Obama Administration and yeah he
told me at the time that just you know a
little bit of inflation would actually
be good for an economic recovery coming
out of kovid and the lockdowns I I don't
think that he meant this much inflation
uh and you know his his former his you
know Harvard colleague Larry summers at
the time had been warning that the the
Biden packages were way too big and were
going to cause this
um you know I I think that basically
we're we're paying the price for
lockdowns what they did to the supply
chains and the monetary Supply now and
it's an increasingly Hefty and really
unfair price uh it's one of those issues
that you hear people who even who aren't
even that politically engaged talk about
because they just they see it and they
feel it it's this kind of Insidious
hidden tax
and I I don't know I the it the fact
that we're just supposed to kind of
trust the Steady Hand of Jerome Powell
to guide us to a soft Landing or a
slightly bumpy Landing I I hope to God
that happens but something other than a
crash yeah and you know even if if that
does happen which I really hope it does
it's just really unsettling that this is
the system that we have and we've got to
Hope pal and his team have really got
this one uh figured out
Catherine that's a good segue for my
question to you so I want you to do
something that I think will be a little
bit uncomfortable for you Catherine
maybe a little out of your wheelhouse I
want you to imagine that you are an
ordinary person like you're just you're
just like a normal middle class dude
lady type person out there living your
life listening to The Reason Roundtable
every week excited about segment names
and you don't have a lot of individual
direct control over the federal budget
over big economic decisions made in
Washington and yet what we've seen over
the past couple of years is that those
decisions have a big effect on your life
so I want to be clear that I am not
asking you for financial advice here at
least uh not in the regulated by the SEC
sense but maybe give us some Financial
advice no not Financial advice what I
want to know is how should ordinary
people respond here should we just hope
the economy is an airplane and that
j-pal is a good pilot
yeah I it's very very hard for me to put
myself in the shoes of this hypothetical
ordinary person
um or maybe it isn't because the
ordinary person and I have this in
common we have no idea what's going to
happen there is absolutely no way to
make informed decisions uh it seems like
um there are some sort of very very
basic things like uh you know stockpile
eggs or whatever
um that is uh that's a a Prudential
thing to do but um that's limited by
refrigerator space
I mean at least in the United States I
think ordinary people in America now all
have like a refrigerator in their garage
is my understanding uh or at least
that's that's what I hear so they have
room for eggs
um
yeah I don't know I I you know my
personal path has been
um to not own a house not own a car and
just hope that in general like the
government doesn't notice me very much
um and that's working out fine so far
but uh I guess I could improve my odds
of that by like moving to Florida with
Zach
um where the government notices people
less by and large
um I don't know this is I I agree unless
they're teaching woke books in public
school yeah and then it's straight to
jail
um overcooked fish also straight to jail
um the yeah I don't know I think the
ordinary the ordinary person is uh is
probably
understandably baffled just as I am I I
have nothing this is actually something
I also struggle with when people say
you know well what what's a what's the
better system like how do we do this
better and I don't know how to answer
that question without tearing up all of
it right I don't know how to answer that
question without just positing a
radically different world in which
um we have abolished the FED right I
mean you know shout out to my uh Ron
Paul revolutionaries but
um it's quite right that our best cases
of bumpy Landing if not a crash and
um we don't we don't even have the
mechanism of voting which as I'm on
record in this podcast I don't think is
a great mechanism for
um you know for accountability but we
don't even have that with respect to
um to our financial Fates
all right let's see if we can bring do
you have any uh advice on that because I
mean you ask the question answer it no
but I asked the question because I don't
have any advice and I actually wonder
what the best way to think about this is
uh if you are someone especially who has
who is not a sort of professionally
involved in politics if you're someone
who is trying to do something else with
your life and I think it's it's a
genuinely difficult question and it's
actually
it's a question that our politics kind
of increasingly implicitly asks without
ever stating because the because because
so much of our politics now is just
about uh political leaders saying
basically trust me
like you again and it and it is in some
ways the the airplane metaphor works
here because we all get on airplanes and
none of us know how to fly none of us
know like what Boeing's you know we know
just as well as politicians had a crash
a plane so maybe we stormed the cabin
and so you do in the modern world just
trust these trust in these systems and
they basically work and in fact we you
know airplane uh crashes in the United
States airplane deaths are are like at
an all-time low here or pretty close to
it at the same time that's not true with
politics and that's not true in the
economy and I don't and and you know so
again the metaphor sort of makes sense
as a metaphor but I don't think it makes
sense as an as an appropriate response
to how to think about the economy at the
same time what other choice do we have
uh this is this is the world we live in
and
um and it is very difficult to change I
think the big thing that I would just
say to people is uh you know try to take
care of yourself try to find um try to
build resilience into your life and to
the extent that you can get involved in
Paul politics in productive ways that
might actually change this maybe not in
the short term but in the long term that
might be something that is worthwhile
and worth doing so let's try to land
this podcast and bring it in for a soft
Landing with our final segments what
you're watching Zach what have you been
watching reading otherwise consuming in
the past week or so uh well I completed
the uh Madoff the monster of Wall Street
Netflix series which uh I bring up in
part just to shamelessly self-promote
the reason TV video coming out today
that tears it apart uh which I it's a
great Series in that it explains uh in
great detail exactly the mechanics of
what Madoff did it talks with uh the
journalists who were on the ground uh
some of the The
Regulators on the periphery and it
explains exactly how the SEC missed red
flag after red flag after red flag and
then proceeds to make the point that we
need to fund the SEC more and create a
layer on more and more regulations and
The Regulators are very bad at their
jobs therefore let's do more regulations
yes so I took some issue with that and
you can see exactly what kind of the
nature of my critique there is uh by uh
logging into YouTube and recent TV's
Channel today Nick what about you I
watched uh station 11 which is an HBO
series that came out in December of 2021
so it's a little bit more than a year
old it's based on a 2014 novel by a
woman named Emily sink John Mandel and
it is about a post-apocalyptic world
that uh the novel was written before
kovid it was about kind of based off the
worst possible outcomes of a swine flu
that knocks out you know 90 percent of
the population of Earth the HBO show is
fantastic because it came out obviously
during the pandemic and um it's a great
haunting reminder of what lockdown was
like and the you know what do you do in
a world where suddenly everything has
changed and the world looks uh the
future looks incredibly Bleak what I
particularly find deeply moving about
the series which is incredibly well
acted It's haunting in every possible
way but is that there's a movement
through time which calls to mind things
like Slaughterhouse Five by Kurt
Vonnegut uh Bob Dylan slow uh rather
Blood on the tracks album Etc where you
never know what is exactly the actual
moment in time because it's going
forward backwards sideways Etc but uh
station 11 it was uh one of the very
best things I've seen in a world where
there are too many good TV shows to
watch I really recommend station 11
because it brings back I think it'll
bring back to most viewers emotions and
feelings about the lockdowns that we've
already started to repress
um which is really kind of fascinating
because you know just I mean in I I
think about like in the 2008 financial
crisis or the response to that within a
couple years people were saying you know
the real problem was the government
didn't do anything I mean just these
fundamentally false memories and I think
we are already going through that with
lockdown where you know Ron DeSantis I
was always against lockdowns I was
always against this and that
um you know like in fact it's it's good
to kind of remind ourselves of what we
were thinking what we were feeling
during these massive disruptive events
station 11 is fantastic it's I I love
that book and it's also interesting that
HBO produced both station 11 and the
last of us another kind of
post-apocalyptic series that is you know
it's not like a Libertarian Series in a
direct sense but it does it's a a
post-apocalyptic future in which after
after you know it's not a virus it's
technically a fungus but in which
essentially after an infection kills a
lot of the planet the federal government
sort of takes over and becomes basically
an armed gang running a small set of you
know sort of of enclaves just in
horrible brutal authoritarian fashion
like there's a next woman right in the
in the last of us right and there's a
Nick Offerman character who's like a
crazy survivalist who shows up at one
point and like is screaming about it
like his uh his partner like gets really
mad at him and says you you live in a
crazy world where 9 11 was a conspiracy
and the government are all Nazis and
Nick Offerman just looks back and says
the government are all Nazis and in the
show's World we're supposed to
understand that he is the one who is
absolutely totally correct at least I
like to uh I thought the subtitle to the
last of us should have been the
Vindication of Ron Swanson
no but it's just notable that these sort
of uh purveyor of like in some ways the
chief purveyor of upper middle brow kind
of media Elite culture HBO's Sunday
night you know dramas has now done two
of these shows both of which are at
least you know skeptical of kind of the
the world that we lived through in 2020.
uh Catherine what is it uh that you have
been watching or reading or otherwise
consuming uh as this shows lady
correspondent I will uh stick with the
theme and um note that I just got around
to I actually listened to
um the big New York Times magazine piece
on menopause because uh you know that's
where we are right now
um it was done as it was it dropped on
The Daily podcast feed
um but read kind of as a long form thing
um
the piece is great and it's great
because it is the story of a failure of
scientific communication
so basically
um sometime a while back uh there had
been you know it was widely prescribed
hormones for women who were going
through menopause to deal with side
effects of uh of menopause and there was
one study that showed a slightly
elevated risk of
um some kind of cardiovascular side
effects for women and a slightly
elevated risk of uh of breast cancer for
those you know those people who are
taking hormones and overnight basically
this treatment people stopped using it
um you know the the prescriptions
dropped by 60 70 percent
within the first year after the study
came out and it wasn't
it was it was tiny tiny increases in
risk that the Press picked up magnified
overplayed and the Parallels for me are
two one um to the failures of
communication around covet right so just
where where do risks really reside how
do you know what are the trade-offs for
um for different types of mitigation
measures
um and then also uh the communication
around opioids so this this idea that
suddenly there were millions of women
suffering some in some cases very very
serious side effects you know hot
flashes Osteo you know osteoporosis
um a bunch of you know sleeplessness a
bunch of other things
um
because the risks had been exaggerated
by people that they trusted and um and
they were afraid they were afraid to use
legitimate treatments for a condition
that they legitimately had
um because they got scared by some bad
science communicators
and
um the the piece makes very directly
makes the case that more women more
menopausal women specifically younger
women women in their 50s should be on
hormones and aren't right now
um and you know it's it really comes
across as advocacy which I was surprised
by I wouldn't necessarily have expected
that from the Times magazine piece in
this style but there was also a kicker
on the piece which is that a lot of
women who feel like they're not being
listened to by their doctors just use
online services that prescribe these
directly and so it's another case of
kind of a technological workaround to a
broken institution
um that's gatekeeping and so I don't
know I just thought it was you know
maybe a story that reason Roundtable
listeners might skip as they are
demographically on average not
menopausal women and
um you shouldn't skip it because it's
it's it really has so many of the themes
that we talk about
on this podcast all the time
um
and it's it's
I think it will be interesting to see
because I think it's quite possible that
a a New York Times magazine piece
of this size then they've promoted it
everywhere they've released it on every
platform they've done you know take away
bullet points and podcasts and
everything
um I assume they will continue to beat
this drum I do think it could genuinely
change the standard of practice because
women will go to their doctors and say
hey give me these hormones
um I'd love to check back in again in a
year and see if
to see if the standard of care changes
which at least as far as this piece
convinced me it should so New York Times
magazine uh since I spent a lot of this
podcast talking smack about other New
York Times coverage I want to say this
piece was pretty impressive and had a
lot of themes relevant to listeners of
this podcast
I think they work around of Health Care
and in many ways women are leading it
because they've had in many ways the
most constrained and vexed relationship
with the medical industry for a lot of
different reasons is really uh you know
a a long running story or a Continuing
Story that's fantastic and it fits in so
well with so many reason uh themes about
decentralization and dispersion of
information hence knowledge and
effectively new ways of doing business
uh and I agree with you Catherine that
story is phenomenal to read on every
possible level including most basically
like the information that's in it but
then what it's illustrating is just
phenomenal yeah and there were and the
fact that there's not just one but
actually two online providers of these
of hormone replacement therapy and
they're competing right like there's a
at the end of the piece there's like
this description of the different
services that these two companies
provide
um and there's a to be sure in there
right like there's an example of a woman
who is pretty clearly high risk who's
using this service to get hormone
replacement therapy which her doctors
would not recommend um and which is
probably
contraindicated but it's dealt with
quite fairly and quite even-handedly and
um
and yeah the fact that there's not not
only a private alternative but
competition in the private space already
uh I thought was pretty cool
since you mentioned themes we talk about
on this podcast a lot oh no it's a Star
Wars oh it's even better I watched the
third movie in the Ant-Man superhero
series and the 30-somethings film
Ant-Man and Ant-Man and the last man I
see you yeah Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania and uh it's fine I guess
it's the whole thing's really sort of
flat the CGI is kind of terrible it
doesn't feel like it's really all that
together yeah it's fine you know there's
just there's a bunch of odd moments I
think of of maybe some interest to this
podcast
um moments of it's not even
politicization it doesn't even like go
that far but just these tossed off
gestures at politics like there's a
moment when Michael Douglas who's the
Elder Ant-Man points to for reasons
there's in this movie there's a hyper
Advanced Society of ants that uh like
builds like a a super society and he
says it makes the case for socialism and
that's that's just sort of it right and
then there's a bit at the beginning when
the younger ant-man's daughter gets
arrested for trying to stop San
Francisco authorities from clearing a
homeless encampment in a park and then
complains about the high prices of
housing because I guess she's like a an
affordable housing activist maybe I
don't know anyway Modoc is in it and
like everybody loves Modoc you know
that's where the old school comic book
super fans there's a bunch of actors and
superhero costumes shooting finger
lasers at each other just big finger
laser action plus some post-credit
scenes the t's future superhero films
just in case you were not tired of
superheroes there's gonna be a lot more
Kang in Avengers the Kang Dynasty what
I'm saying is it's a Marvel movie and I
watched it thank you all for listening
Matt Welch will be back in the pilots
chair next week trying to bring us to a
soft Landing if you like what you hear
on this podcast you can donate at
reason.com donate that's reason.com
donate support our work
thank you all for listening
[Music]